so next party game against Sky
101 from wait what is that Malaysia
okay yes knight C6 you probably have to
make D4 to
take out B5 so let's see who
continues to
play now okay
F6 yes that's just pretty ambitious
or bad depending on how you want it
okay we  should definitely try to
do something quickly in the center here, let's see how hard black
continues now, yes, of course that goes to D5 a.
You should probably
also
accept the invitation, so now of course the
white squares here at black f are
terribly
weakened, especially since the bishop here
exchanges here very often and then the
white squares look like Swiss
cheese. I can't see where
the knight is going. I can take knight E5
with a terrible
position and if he moves to F3
then the white squares are
really a total catastrophe
is then another interesting question
with which white takes up again because with the
pawn is of course also an option in order to
have F4 later, it is
convenient to play after EF knight
E5, but when I first
castle I then have knight D3 after F4, it
is just very lonely there in front
I don't need to be afraid
that he'll
go in again,
it looks like a very
strange position di
D7, maybe he really wants to move for a long time
even though it looks really crazy. Well, let's
think about F4 knight
D3,
maybe we can prepare it somehow
What's also interesting is
the simple move B3 yes
B3 if he takes queen B3 is a terrible
position white white totally dominates on the
white squares I can move D to F4
so that actually looks very
good and if he doesn't take then well then
I might just do it
Even then he doesn't get a base
on B3, so here you could still
insert F4, but of course I can
play it anyway, it might still be
interesting.
F4, he can
make an intermediate sacrifice with B2, but well, that's
not a
bad thing.
Knight C4 he wins now  Yes,
half a
pace, at least I've now
easily developed my runners.
The question of where to go now.
Runner
D4 is definitely not a bad field,
but I would like to
put some knights there. Well, okay, runner
D4. Don't think about it too long before we
get the fat one  Position for time
wasted, so yes, knight D6 was to be
expected, so let's see how
best to progress here. Ideally,
of course, you would get the knight to E6,
that would be via
C5 knight D2 B3 C5, for example as a route, but
knight C3 isn't bad either
I'm just developing
further now, the position has so much
pressure, maybe
knight E4 will come into consideration on the next move, but
I
don't think that's bad
All sorts of things, no,
come on, don't lose a lot of time.
You would like to
keep a knight here with white because the Hal
is such a beautiful field, but you don't
want to lose too much time either on the clock or in
terms of positioning
because the
developmental advantage is enormous  It's big, yes, he
did that, so now
the question is do you want to hit D6 or
not? At least
then you have new holes on C6
and E6 that you can easily get to
or does it make sense
to
wait for another move here? I'll take that one
out there is already an enormous
pressure position, okay, he has opened the e-line,
check
that
out and now the
question is, do you have anything better than
tower E6, i.e. the normal
reinforcement trains, runner F1, maybe
the IDE runner
B5, he can just answer A6, so
I answer  Go
in there, that should
be good.
Rade tur1 he would still have knight
F5. It's a question of whether you
should really prevent knight F5 in
the position. He can't
play C6 well either. He can't play much anyway
do
G4 knight F5 completely
prevent it so yes of course he can
do that but the question is whether he
can ever beat E6 so now let's try
bishop B5 he can't
do A6 anymore or I can just
beat him yes he can  do but
now of course I get a
pretty strict pawn on E6 which you
can cover right here so
he can't move much at some point he
will make C5
unfortunately you ca
n't try that Bishop C6 Faller C5
missed okay he missed then
we block
Remove it like that and now of
course he can't pull D5 very little at all.
At some point he'll
probably have to do that in order
to
free himself. Put it in there
with the idea, actually, with C6
okay, yes, still C5 okay, let's pull it
away a little  get faster
here,
well, wait a minute, Tower D7 was
threatening,
so now the black position is slowly falling
apart, I only have 19
seconds left, that's the only
problem,
it's a bit stupid, it's just the short amount of time,
otherwise you could easily
go into the endgame here, which
is totally won  Well, I'll do it now
Check,
yes, 4 more seconds but it should
actually be
enough. Checkmate is still quite
comfortable.
Yes, of course it was a nice position
after the opening. I definitely did
n't play quite optimally, but of course there's
a lot of pressure on it,
maybe there was  There are also some
even better sequels, maybe
F5 to take the fpawn,
but overall I think it's pretty
well
done